Travel is one aspect of tourism, but you don't go somewhere just to come back.
Another important point, and this is the sixth aspect of Leiper's theory,...
...is that you will engage in leisure-related experiences.
These are nonobligatory.
You don't have to do them.
They are personally pleasurable, recreational, or creative.
You may, for instance, decide to go snorkeling,...
...lounge on the beach or have a massage.
To a certain degree, tourism has to do with leisure,...
...which is why we often see leisure incorporated into tourism courses...
...as well as hospitality.
Whether we're talking about travel, leisure, or hospitality,...
...all tourism shows the culture of the generating regions...
...and most tourism involves a cultural exchange in the destination region.
This is aspect number seven.
As a tourist, you engage with a different culture.
You're away from your own culture for a while.
This gives rise to a lot of interesting theories about cultural exchange,...
...learning more about yourself and learning more about the culture you go to.
People often say that travel broadens the mind.